cuerpos en el suelo ambulancias y el
coche del sospechoso Antes había
disparado a todo el que se cruzaba
delante de una sinagoga en Jerusalén
hasta el lugar de los hechos fue el
primer ministro Benjamín netanyahu y
también el ultraderechista ministro de
seguridad de Israel
dejé mi mesa de sabbat dejé a mi esposa
dejé a mis hijos Te escucho tienes razón
la carga de la prueba está delante
tenemos que actuar y reaccionar ahora
porque esto no puede continuar así esto
mis amigos estoy aquí para ustedes
Call of Duty
de los lamentos de Israel a la
celebración Palestina como en gaza
hoy afirmamos la ecuación de que cada
acción tiene una reacción y que la
resistencia es capaz de encontrar la
respuesta adecuada a los crímenes de la
ocupación
También en hebrón
esta es una celebración nacional
Palestina de la operación en Jerusalén
que es una fuente de orgullo llamamos a
la gente a celebrar a pesar del dolor
por lo que sucedió ayer en el campamento
de yening la venganza llegó lo antes
posible
los palestinos se refieren a la
operación militar de Israel el jueves en
yenín que dejó nueve palestinos muertos
la comunidad internacional está
preocupada ante los últimos
acontecimientos
subrayamos la urgente necesidad de que
todas las partes rebajen la atención
eviten más pérdidas de Vidas civiles y
colaboren para mejorar la situación de
seguridad en Six Jordania
crece la expectación ante la posibilidad
de una respuesta a gran escala del
gobierno más a la derecha de la historia
de Israel que el domingo recibirá la
visita del secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Antonio blinken